hey you go to high school in Inglewood
think you're gonna get into Harvard I'm
from a poor crime-filled neighborhood
raised by a single mother don't know my
dad blah blah it's cliche allow me to
introduce myself my name is malcolm
adekanbi I'm a straight-a student with
nearly perfect at st. T scores he
probably got like one of those
photogenic brains you mean photographic
memory what I'll just say I mean yeah
you said it yeah reiterating I playing a
punk band with my friends and I'm a 90s
hip-hop you gonna say something or just
stare at me a bad day for most geeks
would be being the butt of jokes some
brother really needs to invent an app
like Waze to avoid all these hood traps
it is time we started expanding our
horizons we're not going to a drug
dealers birthday party but when you live
in the bottoms blog off you go Oh
bad day cuz look like this we were
dancing man if I let this slide we got
what they call a slippery slope nor the
slippery slope is do we got anything to
do a scheme this sexual as down don't
mix well you're not what I'm left in the
backpack did he actually say I'll kill
you and your friends if you don't get
rid of these drugs or just you don't act
like you weren't curious too hey all we
gotta do is find the white people go to
Coachella Lollapalooza we don't know
nothing about drugs you do we need to
know if you're gonna help us okay
nobody's gonna suspect a thing we're
just geeks doing what geeks do I don't
want to go to jail I want to go to
college ah slippery slope that you play
with me my little boy from the hood hey
I am the authority and keeping a proper
rather it's a whole ratio so unless you
got some boobies what like boys don't
cry we're seeing it
allow me to reintroduce myself my name
is malcolm adekanbi can you dig it you
can call me n-word and I can't say it
technically he's gonna be able to say
the word why can okay because I'm
fourteen percent African for just say
the damn word your mind mmm who's reflex